une décision politique en europe celle
du premier ministre espagnol qui
décident de gracier les indépendantistes
catalans emprisonnés et nans tout à
l'heure de pedro sanchez qui avait déjà
ouvert la voie ces ennemis style il ya
quelques semaines sont concernés neuf
dirigeants séparatistes de catalogne
les précisions de notre correspondante à
barcelone clémentine laurent la
réconciliation entre madrid et barcelone
c'est ce que le premier ministre
espagnol est venu plaider ici même au
théâtre mythique du lycée ou en plein
coeur de barcelone
alors ces dernières semaines on était
électrique en espagne car le
gouvernement espagnol le conte se
libérer de prison
les dirigeants indépendantistes catalans
ceux là même qui avaient été condamnés
pour sédition en 2017 mais il ne
s'agirait que d'une grâce partielle
c'est à dire que même s'ils sortent de
prison
il devrait tout de même payer leurs
amendes et il resterait inéligible alors
cette décision du gouvernement ne fait
pas l'unanimité en espagne la droite
espagnole notamment se montre contre
toute forme de grâce est l inverse les
indépendantistes catalans en tout cas
certains d'entre eux devant d'une
amnistie totale
c'est donc dans ce contexte que le
premier ministre pedro sanchez est venu
plaider pour la réconciliation
je vous propose de l'écouter les choses
local robert voves espagne ce qu'a
décidé le gouvernement espagnol
c'est d'affronter le problème de
rechercher l'union c'est pourquoi demain
dans l'esprit constitutionnel de
concorde
je proposerai au conseil des ministres
d'accorder la grâce aux neuf personnes
condamnées dans le procès et qui sont en
prison curieuse pas la même pression la
grâce ne sera officielle que ce mardi
après réunion du conseil des ministres
les prisonniers devraient être libérés
dans la foulée érection cet après midi
des espagnols dans les rues de madrid et
côté je considère qu'ils s'en sortent
bien et que si quelqu un frein la loi et
n'est pas puni et bien il recommencera à
faire ce qu'il veut et donc ils peuvent
aller encore plus loin quand ils le
veulent a tiré sur la corde et fixer eux
mêmes les limites ils sont en prison
déjà depuis quelques années et ils vont
leur épargner une partie des années
qu'il leur reste à faire
parce que c'est une peine très élevé qui
leur a été infligé alors il me semble
que c'est un pas nécessaire pour
dépasser cette situation qui est
pitoyable pour la catalogne avec cette
grâce ce que nous faisons c'est leur
donner raison après avoir enduré un
procès avoir été poursuivis avoir été en
prison maintenant c'est comme si tout
cela n'avait servi à rien c'est le
sentiment que j'ai